good morning good morning ladies and
gentlemen my name is Stefan Simon I'm
director of Yale's Institute for the
heritage here on West Campus an
institute which is cutting across the
colorless Copic academic landscape at
Yale working alongside Yale's
magnificent and rich collections center
of British art Peabody Museum the
Beinecke the University Art Gallery and
with faculty and students from all
departments from engineering to art
history from chemistry to religious
studies from business to law all for one
aim to enhance sustainable preservation
of cultural heritage interpretation and
access in service to the global
conservation community so welcome to
Yale and welcome to New Haven by the way
the city and university of Dean Keller
one of the famous monuments men who were
trying to rescue and protect cultural
heritage in the Second World War I thank
you all for accepting our invitation
joining us here in the second row of
workshop on current crisis co-hosted
again with the Victoria and Albert
Museum London under the unesco patronage
let me briefly talk a little bit about
the who the what and the why of today's
workshop the ongoing destruction and
loss of cultural heritage in North
Africa and the Middle East remains a
cause for global concern and
condemnation at our first workshop on
capturing crisis in London almost
exactly a year ago we have discussed not
only the extent of loss in cultural
heritage but also the impact of this of
these war crimes as Irina Bokova says on
the local and global society and their
ability to recover and forgive this week
the eighth United Nations global
colloquium of university presidents will
be held at Yale convened on behalf of un
secretary-general ban ki-moon presidents
and faculty members from 30
international universities have arrived
or are arriving to attend this year's
program takes the team preservation of
cultural heritage focusing on issues of
key importance to societies universities
and major museums worldwide there are
also highly ranked on the United Nations
and UNESCO agenda the workshop on
cultural crisis is one of
many satellite events to the UN GC and
we hope it may inform it on identifying
priorities setting out a pathway for the
academic community to better collaborate
for the preservation of cultural
heritage around the globe our co-hosts
from the Victorian Albert Museum Vernon
Rapley and Martin wrote who have been
with us in this undertaking from the
very first minute realizing the
important role museums can play in this
field which is extending way beyond
resume walls in his concluding marks
nothing wrote the director of the V&A
said there will be a second step and
this is the beginning and here we are
again exchanging and sharing information
learning from each other and seeking
solutions to some of the most urgent
challenges which out our cultural
heritage is facing today also this
workshop is held under UNESCO patronage
and we are looking forward to hear it's
director-general Madame Irina Bokova
tonight addressing the issue of culture
and crisis in a public lecture in our
school of management I would also like
to use this opportunity to thank my
colleagues in the Institute for
preservation of cultural heritage here
on West Campus especially in the Office
of International Affairs and around Yale
a hundred colleagues or more have been
working for months to set this united
nation global colloquium on track
organized in myriad of satellite events
lectures experimental projects and art
installations panel discussions and
workshops so we have quite some exciting
days ahead I think not every day the UN
secretary-general comes to campus and
not every day we can hear him speak
about the topic so close to our hearts
the preservation of cultural heritage
most importantly however I would like to
say that this workshop is about you who
came to join us from around the world
who are ready to share your knowledge
and expertise with us for you who come
from universities research institutes
museums I am very happy to welcome
representatives from a chrome and
e-commerce both advisory bodies to the
world heritage convention from the state
boards of antiquities for example in
Mali in Nigeria key international
players and preservation
like the Getty conservation Institute
the world monument fund the US State
Department the Smithsonian azar NGOs
like Indian pride project or SIA in our
discussion on culture in crisis today on
West Campus for many of you this has not
been easy many of you can just reserve a
ticket online jump on a plane and travel
the world and and we often tend to
forget how privileged we are in the
Western Hemisphere and how this may
shape our view on the issues we are
dealing with in London last year some of
you may remember I pledge to give
especially those colleagues a better
voice who are in my opinion the true
monuments men and women who are
defending our common cultural heritage
in the first line on the ground we made
progress you came from us from Brazil
Chile I hope I don't forget a country
China Czech Republic Ethiopia France
Ghana India Italy Japan Jordan Korea
Mali Nigeria Peru Poland South Africa
Sweden Tanzania Turkey the UK the US not
from my home country Germany but from
everywhere else and but we are still not
quite there I think there are still
those who could not join us for various
and I have to say often outrageous
regions reasons colleagues from
countries like Iran Iraq Syria and Yemen
we will hear some of their stories by
video and in powerpoints and I'm aware
how much frustration this has cost you
and us and how nerve-racking these days
of planning and waiting were but I want
to say we have no choice but to continue
this struggle if we want to be an Agora
for discussing how to better preserve
cultural heritage we must listen to your
voice for me the last point in last
year's London declaration on current
crisis is a very important one it calls
us to support cultural heritage
professionals in countries suffering or
at risk of suffering cultural crisis and
appeals to every decision maker
organization individual to be generous
innovative and dynamic in their support
so cultural heritage is the essential
record of human existence and identity
it is the threat of continuity for which
people search
when the rhythm of everyday life has
been shattered we know that many of us
devoted our careers to the preservation
of cultural heritage we know how part
how important it is the preservation of
cultural heritage is arguably one of the
Grand Challenges of the contemporary
world similar to other Grand Challenges
such as world health and environmental
sustainability and and why here at Yale
I think universities are particularly
well positioned to Forge and accept an
effective response that that's these
challenges we are working in a very
interdisciplinary well hopefully in a
transdisciplinary setting I call this
one's a kaleidoscopic landscape here at
Yale and we are committed to research
and teaching and we have wonderful
students who came to Yale to learn how
to make the world a better place we want
them also to learn why our cultural
heritage deserves to be protected and
this is why we chose to host this
colloquium here at Yale in that sense
please allow me to finish by quoting our
president Peter Salovey
who said the future of the past is here
now at Yale and thank you all again for
joining us here and wish you a
successful workshop and give the word to
my colleague and friend Vernon Bradley
thank you good morning everybody my name
is Vernon Ravi I'm the security director
of the Victorian Albert Museum and I
also lead the VNA's culture in crisis
program I bring the apologies of our
director martin wroath who sadly is
unable to join us today but will join
tomorrow we hope if his plane is on time
and it's I know he very much would have
liked to have been here today to support
the efforts and the collaboration with
Yale he's truly an inspirational
character in this field in the field of
cultural heritage protection and
preservation and his support for us in
the museum and encouragement in the UK
to strive for greater things is a true
inspiration for us so the Victorian
Albert Museum for those of you don't
know a Museum in London we attract about
3 and a half million visitors a year
we have collections from all over the
world founded in 1853 we are an
international museum and becoming more
international day-by-day we run bound by
national boundaries and are collecting
treasures from around the world and
value in them and sharing them to create
inspiration in InDesign and art wherever
you come from in the world if you visit
the VNA we think you will find something
both familiar to your own culture and
something that will inspire you and
you'll find amazing the VNA is
incredibly proud to co-host this second
step and whilst I think it's described
as a second step it's there's been many
smaller steps maybe many other steps by
organizations between between these but
these are landmark events maybe in that
I think we should continue to drive them
forward yearly to bring together experts
and to learn from each other we greatly
value our partnership with with Stefan
and they go Institute for the
preservation of cultural heritage and
we're grateful again for the support of
UNESCO it's been a year since our last
conference and a lot has happened and
I'm pleased to see so many familiar
faces and also new participants from
around the world and congratulations
Stefan for encouraging people and
supporting them to come to this
important event we have a very busy
schedule today many of our speakers will
sadly describe terrible events but there
will also hopefully be messages of help
and perseverance to to inspire us and to
drive us forward in our fight what I
learned from the London conference last
year is there are so many people who
want to do something they want to help
there are people that are helping in
their own way and maybe the one common
complaint that that arose then and has
continued since is a lack of
coordination a lack of any too much
duplication of effort and I'm not sure
that we will necessarily be able to
achieve a great deal of coordination or
to control people in their efforts to
support that the greater work
but what I do believe is that by
bringing people together in events like
this and working closely together and by
understanding what each of us are doing
we can save some of that duplication at
least and better understand what each of
us can offer this has been a particular
concern for the VNA for the last year
finding a place that we can help that we
can bring our hopeful experience and our
knowledge to bear in a productive way in
a way that is not being dealt with
necessarily by other people by
supporting work that is existing and
also looking for new ways that we can
assist we have to acknowledge the work
of other organizations the British
Museum in particular
Oxford University people at Peter stone
in the UK who are doing fantastic
working in this area and slowly we have
formulated a number of strains of work
and one of them I will describe later on
today which our most recent thoughts and
it's not without controversy or problems
but I'll try and explain a little later
how we believe copies in particular may
be digital copies nowadays can create a
forum and a way of saving and preserving
cultural heritage for the future we are
also working on a number of other
smaller projects maybe we are working
with the trade and universities in the
United Kingdom to set up what might
become a gold standard for the behavior
of the trade within the trafficking of
cultural goods we're very keen at this
point not to look for true Kony and
legislation or regulation but to look at
a way of working with these people to
ensure that we provide the best possible
standard we can and to protect cultural
heritage from entering the United
Kingdom we're also working with a number
of working groups to assist the police
and the military in the UK wherever we
can but today the most important thing
is that we learn from you all we have an
excellent program prepared for Stefan
thank you
and I must apologize for being not as
involved in the preparation of today's
conference as I should have been as
co-host so I apologize for that Stefan
but
done an amazing job without without our
assistance in that way I don't want to
take any for any further time we want to
give as much time as possible to to our
speakers I hope that you all today will
find something inspiring to take back
and to assist you in fighting the good
fight to protect cultural heritage from
whatever threats it may face and that we
all leave here today a little bit better
connected and a little bit more
understanding of which each other can do
and what all of us can offer thank you